[Musique]
on
que vous soyez invisible comme des ondes
[Musique]
donc tu vois à travers les gens pour ça
faut passer des heures dans la rue il
passe ma vie déjà toi et ta bonne donc
les en fait on va passer une étape
supérieure
je crois que c'est efficace la de ballon
va faire de l'argent que tu est
introduite par les couilles avec ta
grande gueule dans trois mois tu es mort
c'est pas des conneries ce livre est une
grosse bosse là très vétustes ou pas
l'astuce le cros tu proposes moi je
propose quoi trouver quoi s'attache à
circuler
[Musique]
tuer quelqu'un
ce serait quoi
je m'apprête à tambour battant white
irrigants oui genou bleus tort quand on
me bon père j'avais déjà l'écho avec des
tanks les fois que je m'arrête à tambour
et attend oui tu le dois
[Musique]